bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 politique sur terre vite
sur téléphiles dernière ligne droite
avant les élections régionales de
décembre la campagne a été suspendu en
raison des attentats par certaines
formations m et le scrutin est lui
maintenu vous entendrez au cours de
cette émission claude bartolone le
président de l'assemblée nationale a été
désigné par les socialistes pour
succéder à jean paul huchon à la tête de
l'ile-de-france entretien réalisé le 9
novembre lors de son meeting yvelinois
amante elle la ville mais je reçois tout
d'abord pour débuter cette émission
david douillet bonsoir bonsoir et député
des yvelines candidat dans le
département aux régionales numéro deux
sur la liste les républicains derrière
valérie pécresse
et puis aussi depuis la fin du mois
d'octobre secrétaire départemental donc
des républicains alors je le disais
certains et certaines formations ont
suspendu la campagne politique
officiellement ce n'est pas vraiment le
cas pour les républicains vous continuez
les réunions ce ne sont plus des
meetings ce sont des aides et des
réunions aujourd'hui vous organiser
parce que vous avez voulu continuer les
échanges avec les électeurs en fait on a
suspendu on a respecté le deuil la
semaine dernière nous avons maintenu une
réunion d'ailleurs avec valérie ils n'en
ignoraient pas meeting c'était digne au
départ s'était transformée en eau
réunion pas la suite au chesnay jeudi
soir pour en réalité et sans affiches et
sans parler directement des régionales
pour accueillir les gens qui avaient
prévu de venir
plus des deux tiers qui sont venus pour
pratiquer un échange voilà et pour
expliquer aussi et bien ça tombe
d'interrogations qui étaient présents
dans la bande ans dans l'inconscient
collectif géré ou dans le conscient
collectif plus tôt
quant à l'impact et l'incidence de la
région
sur le sourd sur l'émotion de sécurité
plus particulièrement parce que la
campagne aujourd'hui a clairement changé
on parle beaucoup plus de sécurité
forcément oui elle s'est modifié un
petit peu elle s'est alourdie sur les
propositions en termes de sécurité
même si dans le programme de valérie
pécresse
la sécurité était très brillant
notamment dans les transports
on va détailler le programme dans un
instant je voudrais juste revenir encore
sur les événements qui sont traversées
par le pays au lendemain des attentats
il était question de cette union sacrée
pendant quelques jours et puis après il
ya eu cette séance à l'assemblée
droite et gauche se sont déchirés aucun
élu de droite par exemple s'est levé
pour l'hommage aux policiers aux
pompiers de manuel valls mal à la
ministre taubira aussi été sifflé vous
qui êtes député comment vous avez vécu
ce moment parce que le lendemain la
séance d'après à l'assemblée a été
beaucoup plus calme mais ce jour là ça a
été assez très très mal je vous avoue
que j'ai eus ont des parlementaires ce
jour je vous dis d'ailleurs je suis
partie l'hémicycle voilà je ne
supportais pas et d'ailleurs je n'étais
pas le seul je ne supportais pas
l'ambiance qui a eue ce jour là c'est
presque avec l'âge de vos collaborateurs
je n'ai ni cautionner ni les uns ni les
autres parce que les attitudes ont été
partagés croyez moi et il faut pas
minimiser
l'attitude et la majorité actuelle les
deux étaient à mettre dans le même
panier
dans le même panier si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi par contre ce que je
peux dire aussi c'est que valérie
pécresse a été d'une dignité incroyable
parce qu'elle a posé une question ce
jour là voilà une question qui était
très clair qui était la suivante en
substance à ce que tous ceux qui sont en
capacité d'employer des individus fichés
puisse être avertis est notamment
particulièrement dans les
transformations et notamment sur les
contres des fiches sncf à la sncf et à
la ratp c'est pas rien lors du discours
de françois hollande au congrès parce
que vous étiez présent aussi tous les
députés
vous n'avez pas applaudi non non j'ai
pape le dis parce que même si l'attitude
du chef de l'état a été extrêmement
dignes et
même si il a évoqué un certain nombre de
préconisations d'ailleurs que la droite
est en partie pillée en particulier les
républicains préconisait depuis des mois
depuis les attentats de charlie hebdo
j'ai trouvé qu'il manquait un pan
important dans son discours qui est tout
simplement celui qui concerne les
musulmans les vrais musulmans de france
ce qui correspond à peu près 5 5
millions de personnes
il n'a pas eu un seul mot pour leur
expliquer où expliqué à certain nombre
de préconisations pour les protéger eux
mêmes
de quel type des préconisations rien
attendu d'être beaucoup plus précis et
beaucoup plus vindicatif quant au
nettoyage dont on a besoin dans
entre attention à l'image des karcher
autres les bon prédicateur et les
mauvais voilà et surtout pour expliquer
que l' amalgame n'a pas sa place ici
dans notre pays et de protéger les
musulmans de france de mettre en place
des préconisations manière urgente de
faire en sorte qu' on est et on
construise réellement une bonne fois
pour toute un islam de france et je
dirais même j'avais plus loin un islam
d'europe
voilà pour que les gens qui puissent
prodigués cette fabuleuse religion
puisse enfin doivent être formés dans
notre pays
pratique est complètement notre langue
être complètement investis de notre
culture pour qu'ils n'aient aucun
décalage ni aucune suspicion quant à
l'acceptation des valeurs de la
république c'est ce que de l'acier
vous n'avez pas eu voilà qui explique le
fait que vous n'ayez pas exactement
parce que je suis je suis énervé par
rapport en fait que dieu sait si la
gauche en particulier n'a de cesse que
d'aller caresser dans le sens du poil
notamment dans les banlieues
beaucoup de personnes de jeunes qui
sont influençables parapente et cela ne
sont pas protégés et à aucun moment le
chef de l'état évoque une piste pour que
enfin et sur le long terme
des jeunes qui peuvent êtres en
perdition est allé sur de mauvais et de
mauvaises rails on puisse leur apporter
une solution dans leur vie un projet de
vie à aucun moment cela n'a été évoqué
ça donc j'ai considéré que on avait
oublié 5 millions de français
voilà pour votre position sur 7 sur ses
différentes déclarations autour la
situation d attente à la situation que
traverse la france aujourd'hui mais vous
êtes venus aussi parce qu'il ya des
élections les élections sont maintenues
on l'a dit la campagne été suspendus
plus ou moins longtemps en fonction des
formations politiques mais malgré tout
il faudra aller voter les 6 et 13
décembre pour les élections régionales
dans les propositions
c'est d'ailleurs lui un peu à la
sécurité aussi parce que ça pourrait
déboucher sur le renforcement de la
vidéosurveillance aux abords des lycées
il y avait cette proposition qui a été
faite ya pas très longtemps par valérie
pécresse c'est organiser des tests de
dépistage salivaire sur la consommation
de cannabis dans les établissements
franciliens rappelle que les lycées
dépendent de la région par exemple
oui et puis on sait aussi et surtout que
c'est une énorme source de revenus pour
les milieux radicaliser faut pas
l'oublier
donc voilà on l'a on privilégie une
proposition qui peut aussi il n'ya pas
que les frappes en syrie pour détruire
les les
la faculté de se financer aussi dans nos
lycées dans notre société française
il faut couper court à ces trafics qui
pour une grande majeure partie d'entre
eux c'est une manne qui vient abonder
les caisses mais ses réserves jeudi
c'est faisable d'organiser des
dépistages salivaires
mais désolé de cette liste deux ans il
vole quand on a une volonté politique
tout est faisable je pense
qu'aujourd'hui allé dans les
établissements et obliger les élèves à
se soumettre à ces tests là légalement
ça va être compliqué mais il faut
travailler avec l'assemblée nationale et
la loi donc ce n'est pas pour tout de
suite il faudra attendre en tout cas au
moins la prochaine
oui mais tout va de paire julien même
dans les camps sports quand il s'agit de
de créer enfin de fluidifier enfin nos
routes nos autoroutes de renforcer notre
maintenance sur les voies ferrées etc
etc et de créer de nouvelles lignes
il s'agit aussi par le législateur et en
particulier à travers l'état l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat d'en passer par la
loi pour accélérer affirmé le les
modifications liées au grand paris aussi
donc il ya beaucoup de préconisations
qui sont faites sur ces sujets et qui
devront de toute façon passer par
l'étape nationale pour redescendre à
l'étape régionale
de toute façon et sur la question de la
région sur les pouvoirs de la région et
sur les finances de la région l'une des
propositions concernant les transports
pour l'ancien ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur puis du budget valérie
pécresse c'est l'achat de nouvelles
rames de rer par exemple d'accélérer la
modernisation du réseau qui a été engagé
par par la majorité actuelle
financièrement financièrement c'est
incroyable aujourd'hui la majorité
actuelle achète les rames content c'est
sûr que on donne on donne tout tout tout
le tout la manne financière dont on a
besoin de manière immédiate alors que
dans n'importe quelle société digne de
ce nom est bien géré on est
métal les paiements et on peut étaler on
pourrait passer un contrat parce que il
s'agit quand même de 700 ram a changé
c'est l'engagement de valérie pécresse
d'ici 2021
c'est pas anodin et on pourrait imaginer
d'ailleurs il faut le faire de négocier
un partenariat financier avec ceux qui
vont ils fabriqués pour étaler les
paiements sur la durée de vie des
produits concernés
donc tout ça concourt à ce à dire que on
peut accélérer par des accords fait avec
les constructeurs
l'achat de ces nouvelles âmes se
consacre elle est capable de s'engager
au changement total de toutes les rames
d'ici 2021 c'est pas loin non plus
aussi c'est pas anodin aussi que de que
de constater que chaque année la
maintenance de c2c de ces rames qui sont
obsolètes
elles ont pour certaines plus de trente
ans de d'existence et certaines ont plus
de 40 ans pour les transiliens et bien
l'économie en rénovant et en achetant de
nouveaux matériels c'est inné une
économie parents de 340 millions d'euros
c'est pas rien non plus qu'il y aura des
étincelles à l'économie il va falloir
faire des choix de toute façon pour
organiser les différents points de
programme
je rappelle juste une chose importante
c'est que toutes ces préconisations sont
financés sans augmenter les impôts
je vous donne mais ça s'en ressent
déconstruire ce qui avait été fait le
pass navigo par exemple intéressant il
est maintenu on maintient il est
maintenant messieurs mais sans sens des
mets par contre la lutte contre les
fraudes vous avez combien ça comme et
renforçant la lutte contre les fraudes à
200 millions d'euros par an a récupéré
en luttant efficacement contre les
fraudes
c'est pas rien non plus c'est la raison
pour laquelle est là je reviens à ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure il faut en
passer par le législateur aussi là et
encore d'autoriser les personnels de
sécurité les policiers la police
ferroviaire etc à pouvoir demander des
pièces d'identité parce que neuf fois
sur dix les contrevenants donnent une
fausse il autres tc 200 millions d'euros
en moins dans les caisses du stif la
société de transports d'île de france
que préside le président de la région et
allemands on pourra pas développer tous
les points de programme en va être pris
par le temps
comme vous faire réagir sur ce sondage
c'est le premier sondage en
ile-de-france après les attentats
justement et valérie pécresse qui est
donnée gagnante par l'institut ipsos à
40% au second tour 33% d'intentions de
vote au premier léger recul mais c'est
surtout le front national qui progresse
on va dire que les attentats ont profité
même si le mot n'est n'est pas forcément
le plus approprié au front national
moi aujourd'hui je crois à ses électeurs
d'abord on est très sommes par rapport à
ces sondages ne sont que une semaine
qu'une prise de température il reste
encore plus de deux semaines de campagne
et là on s'aperçoit de quoi on
s'aperçoit que le travail qu'a fait
toutes les équipes de valérie pécresse
son travail personnel sa crédibilité
ces propositions ça fonctionne et les
gens le comprennent et on voit que le
depor bascule vers le front national
il s'agit plutôt de la gauche et de
l'extrême gauche et des listes de
monsieur dupont il ya malgré tout un
léger recul enfin c'est surtout selon ce
sondage en tout cas d'ipsos un léger
recul de la liste menée par valérie
pécresse continue à être cédés qu'à
voilà et vous restez pour l'instant
donné en tête sur les différents
sondages
juste une dernière question valérie
pécresse a annoncé qu'elle quitterait
son poste de député si elle est élue à
la tête de la région
et vous c'est une question que je me
pose vraiment tout dépend des
attributions que je pourrais avoir par
valérie elle souhaite et moi aussi
d'ailleurs que je m'occupe du
développement économique
et dieu sait si t'as sujet extrêmement
important pour rappel la geôle de france
et 30 % du pib de la production de
richesses du pays
c'est 684 milliards pour la région mais
encore un potentiel énorme à développer
la l'ancienne majorité enfin la majorité
qu'elle travaille donc l'arrêt dépend de
ce qu'on leur propose et je pense avoir
si vous ne vous moi je vous l ai dit ça
mais vous avez quelqu'un devant vous
qui n'est pas pour le forcément pour le
cumul des mandats mais dans le cumul ni
le cumul des mandats dans le temps
voilà donc chaque chose en son temps
d'abord gagner qu'un congrès merci david
douillet député des yvelines en tout cas
pour l'instant candidats aux régionales
en ile-de-france numéro deux sur la
liste yvelines pour les républicains
merci à vous le 7-8 politique se
poursuit à présent avec un entretien
réalisé avec claude bartolone le
président de l'assemblée nationale
candidats pour les socialistes sur cette
région ile-de-france entretien je leur
précise réalisée avant les évènements
qui ont frappé paris lors d'un
déplacement à mantes la jolie c'était le
9 novembre pour l'instant officiellement
la campagne du parti socialiste est
suspendu jusqu'au 28 novembre
l'autre bartolone au soir soir est donc
venu ici sur les terres de
mantes-la-ville sur les terres du front
national déjà les yvelines c'est un
département difficile pour la gauche
là c'est presque mission impossible vous
aimez relever les défis et challenges
il n'y a pas de territoire interdit pour
la gauche il n'y a pas de territoire
interdit pour l'espérance est ici c'est
encore plus important d'y venir
d'abord parce que l'on voit quand la
gauche est divisée lorsque les
socialistes sont divisés ce que ça amène
à reconnaître ou à connaître comme
résultats électoraux
et puis lorsque l'on voit comment ici
l'extrême droite essaye d'opposer les
uns aux autres il y à encore plus de
nécessité d'y venir pour tenir un
discours du tous ensemble et un
d'histoire républicain ça veut dire que
votre principal adversaire dans cette
campagne en tout cas pour gagner des
voix supplémentaires est arrivé en tête
c'est le front national
l'adversaire aujourd'hui non la première
des choses que je défends ce
rassemblement des socialistes et les
rassemblement de la gauche et des
écologistes
et lorsque ce rassemblement et de
qualité sur la base d'un projet sur une
certaine vision de la région une région
humide et bien on peut espérer remporter
des succès après c'est évident moi je
lis j'ai deux adversaires j'ai deux
adversaires un l'abstention et 2 la
droite et j'ai un adversaire résolu
sélection droite parce que je n'ai aucun
point de rapprochement avec les thèses
du front national vous parlais justement
du rassemblement de cette gauche des
socialistes mais de la gauche dans son
ensemble ça semble difficile à imaginer
tant les tensions existent encore
aujourd'hui d'imaginer un rassemblement
qu'est ce que vous allez dire à vos
alliés vous en voyez vous verrez ce sera
beaucoup plus facile pour la gauche que
pour la droite pourquoi parce que la
gauche elle sort d'une gestion commune
de cette région regardez comment toute
la gauche se félicitent de la création
du pass navigo
alors que la droite avait voté contre
regardez comment la gauche a réussi à
faire sortir cette région des pages des
faits divers aujourd'hui on parle plus
de scandale quand on parle de lycées de
la région ile de france alors que la
droite regardez les différences qui
peuvent exister pour lui permettre de se
rassembler pour que la droite se
rassemblent un moment donné ils ont des
choix extrêmement important sur lequel
ils devront choisir lorsque je vois les
positions de monsieur de monsieur
dupont-aignan sur le tout voiture et
j'entends les positions de la droite sur
le taux de transport un moment donné ce
sera beaucoup plus difficile de les
rassembler sur un projet que cela sera
difficile pour les socialistes les
communistes les écologistes mettre un
mot justement pour finir là sur cette
question de l'union de la gauche avec
votre prédécesseur jean paul huchon ne
voit pas trop pendant cette campagne
revient en étais-je auriez dû venir à
punta il était à pantin il était présent
au cours des différentes manifestations
et vous savez moi je le dis
jean paul duchon avait pu rassembler
socialiste je n'aurais pas été candidat
c'est parce qu'ils se retrouvaient
critiquer ou même contestée et qu'il
était porteur d'une division des
socialistes que l'on a fait appel à moi
c'est vous sembler légitime le fait
qu'il soit critiqué et qu'il soit
porteur d'une musique à un moment donné
la parole des militants
moi je n'ai pas à me substituer à la
parole des militants mais lorsque l'on a
constaté qu'il était difficile de
réconcilier de rassembler le président
sortant et sa première vice présidente
sortante c'est qu'elle a un problème on
mate et par lesquelles nous sommes à
présent quelques instants du programme
aussi les axes forts que vous allez
défendre dans cette campagne nous
entendu taper sur le front national très
puissant la droite appelé à l'unité mais
il faut aussi faire des propositions
si m d'ailleurs je vais vous le montrez
nous on n'a pas hésité à travailler à
vouvoyer 156 pages 160 proposition 12
engagements
donc je demande de même à vos
téléspectateurs d'aller s'ils ne l'ont
pas ils peuvent le commander
parce que il ya fedex b ya aussi le bar
text s'il le demande on ira leur livrer
à domicile et puis s'ils ont la volonté
de le consulter sur internet ils vont
sur une île de france humaine point fr
ils pourront voir chacune des
propositions
après si vous voulez laisser name que
vous devez dégager une que vous devez
retenir et et porter le plus qui est le
lendemain car dès le lendemain de mon
élection je lancerai en contact avec les
différentes compagnies de transporter un
grand programme pour la sécurité des
femmes dans les transports aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas normal que l'on est plus
80% des femmes qui se plaignent de subir
une violence plus ou moins graves si
tant est que l'on puisse faire une
échelle de richter sur les violences
dans les transports et ce sera le point
le plus important deuxième point c'est
que je ressens aujourd'hui ce qu'est la
situation de la grande couronne
notamment en termes de transport et nous
engagerons un plan d'embauché 2000
chauffeur parce que bien souvent les bus
sont là notamment dans tout le réseau
optile mai
ils sont au dépôt alors que les bus de
la ratp roule donc on aura une volonté
de prendre cela en compte et le
troisième élément moi je ne veux pas
qu'on soit simplement le pays qui
accueille la coop 21 80 chefs d'état
pour faire face à la double transition
écologique et énergétique et plus aucune
décision sera acceptée par la région si
elle ne correspond pas à cette nécessité
de prendre des décisions qui permettent
de préserver la planète et la dernière
pour vous donner une idée précise
j'ai évoqué les transports j'ai évoqué
la sécurité des femmes j'ai évoqué
l'environnement
il y aura aussi une action résolue pour
développer un grand plan culturel parce
que pour éviter cette opposition des uns
aux autres comme on l'a entendu au cours
de cette réunion est bien amené les
femmes les hommes jeunes et moins jeunes
à participer au même élan même partage
d'une émotion culturel ce sera quelque
chose aussi qui sera extrêmement
important on a vu récemment les
présidents des différents conseils
départementaux de la grande couronne
s'unir pour se faire entendre dans le
cadre du grand paris parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment que leur département sont
oubliés c'est le cas des yvelines fait
partie de cette grande couronne quel
message vous fait il son lancement j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire et je le répète
devant votre caméra
moi j'ai espéré un dans la métropole du
grand paris y compris lorsque j'étais
président du conseil général de la seine
saint denis où j'avais présenté un
projet de suppression des départements
de la petite couronne et j'étais pour la
métropole pour deux raisons à la fois la
péréquation entre territoires riches et
territoire pauvre et la péréquation en
termes de logement aujourd'hui sur ces
deux sujets la métropole les égoïsmes
l'ont emporté et a mis les pouces et
bien la métropole existe mais il y aura
la volonté de ma part d'installer une
métropolisation de la régionale i de la
région parce que c'est insupportable de
sentir cette différence qui existe
quelques fois entre grandes chorales
petite couronne et paris intra muros une
toute dernière question les sondages
vous les regardez encore aujourd'hui
bien sûr ça vous inquiète non pas du
tout il y en a deux qui sortent un qui
est publié par valeurs actuelles jeudi
mais ils ont trouvé intelligent de le
sortir
aujourd'hui on peut se demander pourquoi
est un bien meilleur qui ait publié par
l'ifop et i télé
demain qui montrent que le résultat de
l'élection sera dans la capacité de des
socialistes des écologistes et des
communistes de se retrouver au second
tour et j'ai eu l'occasion de le
démontrer l'année dernière en cette
année nous avons alors que nous avons
des discussions quelquefois musclé entre
partenaires mais nous avons su trouver
le chemin de rassemblement et la senza
n'y est resté à gauche
merci beaucoup plus de barcelone merci à
vous pour refermer ce 7,8 politique un
mot de la réunion annoncée dans les
yvelines par europe ecologie les verts
un meeting de campagne pour les
régionales était programmé pour ce mardi
24 novembre ce soir donc par les
écologistes il a été annulé dans un sous
sa forme initiale à la place sera
organisée donc une soirée d'échangés de
réflexion sur les événements du 13
novembre et sur les propositions que
peuvent porter europe écologie et les
verts les différents élus pour l'avenir
c'est la fin de ce set 8 politique on se
retrouve mardi prochain à 18h30 invités
notamment valeron de saint-just le
candidat tête de liste front national en
ile-de-france et puis et bien sûr chaque
soir dans le journal le point sur cette
campagne des régionales
toutes nos émissions sont à voir en
replay dernière invitée politique
d'ailleurs vendredi dernier dans le
journal c'était thierry gonot tête de
liste yvelines de lutte ouvrière son
entretien est à revoir dès à présent en
replay donc sur notre site
excellente soirée sur notre antenne